The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I wanted to give
everybody a more conceptual
idea of what big O notation as
well as, hopefully, answer any
lingering questions you might
have about object-oriented
programming.
So I have these notes, and I
type them up, and they're
pretty detailed.
So I'm just going to
go through some
points kind of quickly.
Who's still kind of unclear
about why we
even due big O notation?
So who can explain why we do
big O notation quickly?
What is it?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
Exactly.
So big O notation gives us an
upper bound on how long
something is going to take.
Now, something that's important
to remember is it's
not a time bound.
So something that's often
confusing is that people say,
oh, this is something that'll
tell us how long our programs
going to run.
That's actually not the case.
Big O notation informs
how many steps
something's going to take.
And so why is that important?
Well, I mean I look at all you
guys, a couple of you have
laptops out.
Everybody's computer
run something
at a different speed.
Right?
But if we say something is big O
of n, what we're saying here
is we're saying that the worst
case number of steps your
program is going to take is
going to be linear with
respect to the size
of the input.
So if my computer is five
times faster than your
computer, my computer
will probably run
it five times faster.
As the size of the input grows,
I'm going to expect a
linear speedup in the amount
of time it's going to take.
So why is that important?
At the bottom of page one,
big O notation, we are
particularly concerned with the
scalability of our functions.
So what the O notation does is
it might not predict what's
going to be the fastest for
really small inputs, for an
array size 10.
You guys know a little bit
about graphs, right?
We have a graph of
x-squared, and we
have a graph of x-cubed.
There's a portion of time where
the graph of x-squared
is actually bigger
than x-cubed.
But then all of a sudden,
there's a point where x-cubed
just goes, whoosh, way bigger
than x-squared.
So if we're in some really small
amount of input, big O
notation might not tell us
what's the best function.
But in big O notation,
we're not
concerned about small inputs.
We're concerned about
really big inputs.
We're concerned about filtering
the genome.
We're concerned about analyzing
data from Hubble,
really huge blocks of data.
So if we're looking at a program
that analyzes the
human genome, like three million
base pairs, some
segment that we're looking at,
and we have two algorithms.
One runs in order n time,
and one runs in
order n-cubed time.
What this means is regardless
of the machine that we're
running on, so this is algorithm
1, this is algorithm
2, regardless of the machine
that we're running on, we'd
expect algorithm 2 to run
approximately n-cubed over n
approximately n-squared
slower.
So with big O notation, you can
compare two algorithms by
just looking at the ratio
of their big O run time.
So if I'm looking at something
that has an array of size two
million as its input, is it
clear that this is going to be
a much better choice?
Ok.
So you'll run into that,
especially a lot of you guys
are taking this for
the purposes
of scientific computing.
So you'll run into big
O notation a lot.
It's important to have a
grasp of what it means.
On the second page of the
handout, I have some common
ones that you'll see.
The first one is
constant time.
We denote constant
time as order 1.
But you'll notice that I have
here is order 1 is equal to
order 10 is equal to order
2 to the 100th.
That's unexpected to a lot of
people who are learning about
big O notation.
Why is this true?
That seems kind of ridiculous.
This is a really big number.
This is really small number.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Exactly.
So we look at a graph of 1 and
a graph of 2 to the 100th.
Ok.
We'll see that even though 2 to
the 100th is much higher,
much bigger than 1, if this is
our input size, as the size of
our input grows, do we see any
change in these two graphs?
No.
They're completely constant.
When you're doing big O
notation, if you run across an
algorithm that does not depend
on the size of the input, OK,
it's always going
to be order 1.
Even if it's like 2 to the
100th steps, if it's a
constant number of times
regardless of the size of the
input, it's constant time.
Other ones you'll see are
logarithmic time.
Any base for logarithmic time
is about the same order.
So order log base 2 of n is
order log base 10 of n.
This is the fastest time
bound for search.
Does anybody know what type
of search we'd be doing in
logarithmic time?
Something maybe we--
AUDIENCE: Bisection time
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Exactly.
Bisection search is
logarithmic time.
Because we take our input.
And at every step, we cut in
half, cut in half, cut in
half, and that's the fastest
search we can do.
The order n is linear time.
Order n log n is the fastest
time bound we have for sort.
We'll be talking about sort
in a couple of weeks.
And order n-squared
is quadratic time.
Anything that is order n to
some variable, so order
n-squared, order n-cubed, order
n-fourth, all of that is
going to be less than order
something to the power of n.
So if we have something that's
order 2 to the n, that's
ridiculous.
That's a computationally very
intensive algorithm.
So on page two, I have some
questions for you.
(1), (2), (3).
Does order 100 n-squared
equal order n-squared.
Who says yes?
All right.
Very good.
How about does order
one quarter n-cubed
equals order n-cubed?
Does order n plus order
n equals order n?
The answer is yes
to all of those.
In the intuitive sense behind
this is that big O notation
deals with the limiting
behavior of function.
So I made some nifty graphs
for you guys to look at.
When we're comparing order 100
n-squared to n-squared n cubed
and 1/4 n-cubed, what people
often think of is what I have
here in the first figure.
So these are the four functions
I just mentioned.
There's a legend in the
top left-hand corner.
And the scale of this is
up to x equals 80.
So you'll see at this
scale, this line
right here is 100 x-squared.
So this is, I think, often a
tripping point is that when
people are conceptualizing
functions, they're saying,
well, yeah, 100 x-squared is
much bigger than x-cubed,
which is a lot bigger
than 1/4 x-cubed.
So for very small inputs,
yes that's true.
But what we're concerned about
is the behavior as the input
gets very, very large.
So now, we're looking at
a size of up to 1,000.
So now we see here, x-cubed,
even though it's a little bit
smaller than 100 x-squared in
the beginning, it shoots off.
x-cubed is much bigger than
either of the 2 x-squared.
And even 1/4 x-cubed is becoming
bigger than 100
x-squared out of 1,000.
So that's an intuitive sense why
x-cubed no matter what the
coefficient is in front of it is
going to dominate any term
with x-squared in it, because
x-cubed is just going to go,
whoosh, real big like that.
And if we go out even further,
let's go out to input size of
50,000, we go out to an input
size of 50,000, we see that
even 100 x-squared versus just
x-squared, alright? they're
about the same.
The x-cubed terms now, they're
way above x-squared.
So the two x-squared terms, 100
versus just 1, as far as
the coefficient goes, they're
about the same.
So this is the scale at which
we're concerned about when
we're talking about big O
notation, the limiting
behavior as your input size
grows very large.
50,000 is not even that large,
if you think about the size of
the genome.
I mean does anybody here bio?
What's like the size of
the human genome.
How many base pairs?
Or even one gene or
one chromosome.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: What's the biggest?
AUDIENCE: It's over 50,000.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, over 50,000.
And we're talking about the
amount of data that we get
back from the Hubble
Space Telescope.
I mean the resolution on those
things are absolutely
ridiculous.
And you run all sorts of
algorithms on those images to
try and see if there's
life in the universe.
So we're very concerned about
the big long term behavior of
these functions.
How about page three?
One last question.
Does order 100 n-squared
plus 1/4
n-cube equal order n-cubed?
Who says yes?
And so I have one more graph.
Down here, these red dots
are 100 x-squared.
These blue circles
are 1/4 x-cubed.
And this line is the sum.
We can see that this line is a
little bit bigger than the 1/4
x-cubed term.
But really, this has no effect
at this far out.
So that's why we're just going
to drop any lower order terms
whenever you're approached with
a big O expression that
has a bunch of constant factors,
it has all sorts of
different powers of n and stuff,
you're always just
going to drop all the constant
factors and just pick the
biggest thing.
So this line right here
is order n-cubed.
Is that clear to everybody?
So now I've gotten through the
basics of how we analyze this
and why are we looking
at this.
Let's look at some code.
So the first example, all of
these things right here, in
Python, we make the assumption
that statements like this, x
plus 1, x times y, all these
mathematical operations are
all constant time.
That's something that
you can just assume.
So for this function down here,
we have constant time,
constant time, constant time,
constant time operation.
So we'd say, this function
bar is what?
What's its complexity?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Constant time.
So the complexity of all these
functions are just a 1,
because it doesn't matter
how big the input is.
It's all going to run
in constant time.
For this multiplication
function here,
we use a for loop.
Oftentimes, when we see for
loops that's just going
through the input, there's a
signal to us that it's going
to probably contain
a factor of O(n).
Why is that?
What do we do in
this for loop?
We say for i in range y.
What does that mean?
How many times do we execute
that for loop?
Yeah, y times.
So if y is really small, we
execute that for loop just a
few number of times.
But if y is really large, we
execute that for loop a whole
bunch of times.
So when we're analyzing this,
we see this for loop and we
say, ah, that for loop
must be O(y).
Does that make sense
to everybody?
OK, good.
Let's look at a factorial.
Can anybody tell me what the
complexity of factorial is?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Order n.
Why is it order n?
AUDIENCE: Because it's
self for loop.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It's the exact same structure.
We have a for loop that's
going through
range 1 to n plus 1.
So that's dependent
on the size of n.
So this for loop is order n.
And inside the for loop,
we just do a
constant time operation.
That's the other thing.
Just because we have this for
loop doesn't mean that what's
inside the for loop is
going to be constant.
But in this case, if we have
order n times, we do a content
time operation.
Then this whole chunk of the
for loop is order n.
The rest of everything else
is just constant time.
So we have constant time plus
order n times constant time
plus constant time, they're
going to be order n.
How about this one?
Factorial 2.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Exactly.
This is also order n.
The only thing that's different
in this code is that
we initialize its
count variable.
And inside the for
loop, we also
increment this count variable.
But both result times equals
num and count plus equal 1,
both of these are constant
time operations.
So if we do n times 2 constant
times operations, that's still
going to be order n.
So the takeaway from these two
examples that I'm trying to
demonstrate here is a single
line of code can generate a
pretty complex thing.
But a collection of lines
of code might
still be constant time.
So you have to look at
every line of code
and consider that.
I've thrown in some
conditionals here.
What's the complexity
of this guy?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
This is also linear.
What's going on here?
We initialize a variable count
that's constant time.
We go through character
in a string.
This is linear in the
size of a string.
Now we say if character equal,
equal t, this character equal,
equal t, that's also a constant
time operation.
That's just asking if this one
thing equals this other thing.
So we're looking at
two characters.
We're looking at two numbers.
Equal, equal or not equal
is generally a
constant times operation.
The exception to this might be
a quality of certain types,
like if you define a class and
you define a quality method in
your class, and the equality
method of your class is not
constant time, then this equal,
equal check might not
be constant time.
But on two strings, equal,
equal is constant time.
And this is constant
time as well.
So linear in the size
of a string.
Something that's important when
you're doing this for
exams, it's a good idea to
define what n is before you
give the complexity bound.
So here I'm saying n is equal
to the size of a string.
So now, I can say this
function is order n.
What I'm saying is that it's a
linear with respect to the
size or the length
of a string.
Because sometimes, like in the
one where there is the input x
and y, the running time was only
linear in the size of y.
So you want to define that n was
equal to the size of y to
say that it was order n.
So always be clear.
If it's not clear, be sure
to explicitly state
what n is equal to.
This code's a little
more tricky.
What's going on here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That was perfect.
So just to reiterate, the for
loop we know is linear with
respect to the size
of a string.
We have to go through every
character in a string.
Now, the second is if char in
b string, when we're looking
at big O notation, we're worried
about the worst case
complexity in upper bound.
What's the worst case?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
If the character is not in b
string, we have to look at
every single character
in b string before
we can return false.
So that is linear.
This one single line, if
character in b string, that
one line is linear
with respect to
the size of b string.
So how do we analyze the
complexity of this?
I want to be able to
touch the screen.
We have this for loop.
This for loop is executed.
Let's call n is the length
of a string.
This for loop is executed
n times.
Every time we execute
this for loop, we
execute this inner body.
And what's the time bound
on the inner body?
Well, if we let m equal the
length of b string, when we
say that this check is order m
every time we run it, then we
run an order m operation
order n times.
So the complexity is--
we use something of
size m, n times.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Just order n, m.
So we execute an order m check
order n time, we say this
function is order n, m.
Does that make sense
to everybody?
Because you'll see the
nested for loops.
Nested for loops are very
similar to this.
While loops combine the best of
conditionals with the best
of for loops.
Because a while loop has a
chance to act like for loop,
but a while loop can also
have a conditional.
It's actually possible to write
a while loop that has a
complex conditional that also
executes a number of times.
And so you could have one single
line of code generating
like an order n-squared
complexity.
Let's look at factorial 3.
Who can tell the complexity
of factorial 3?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It's also linear.
It's interesting that factorial
is always linear
despite its name.
We have constant time
operations.
How many times does the
while loop executed?
AUDIENCE: n times.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, n times.
And what's inside the body
of the while loop?
Constant time operations.
So we execute a bunch of
constant time operation n
times order n.
How about this char
split example?
This one's a little tricky
because you're like, well,
what's the complexity of len?
In Python, len's actually a
constant time operation.
This example's very crafted
such that all of the
operations that are here
are constant time.
So appending to a list
is constant time.
And indexing a string
So what's the complexity
of char split?
Constant time.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Who would agree
with constant time?
And who would say it's
linear time?
OK, yeah.
Very good.
It is linear time.
That's a correct intuition.
We say while the length of the
a string is not equal to the
length of the result, these
are two constant time
operations.
Well, what do we do?
We append a value to the result,
and then we add up
this index.
So when is this check
going to be equal?
This check's going to be equal
when the length of the result
is equal to the length
of a string.
And that's only going to
happen after we've gone
through the entire a string,
and we've added each of its
characters to result.
So this is linear with respect
to the size of a string.
Something that's important to
recognize is that not all
string in the list operations
are constant time.
There's a website here that
first off, it says C Python if
you go to it.
C Python just means Python
implemented in C, which is
actually what you're
running, C Python.
So don't worry about that.
There's often two time
bound complexities.
It says the amortized time
and the worst case time.
And so if you're looking for big
O notation, you don't want
to use the amortized time.
You want to use the
worst case time.
And it's important to note that
operations like slicing
and copying actually aren't
constant time.
If you slice a list or a string,
the complexity of that
operation is going to depend
on how big your slice is.
Does that makes sense?
Does the way that a slice works
is that walks through
the list until it gets to the
index, and then keeps walking
until the final index, and
then copies that and
returns it to you.
So slicing is not
constant time.
Copying is similarly
not constant time.
For this little snippet
of code, this is just
similar to what we--
yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So this is
what I was saying.
You want to define what n is.
So we say something like n
equals the length of a string.
And then you can say
it's order n.
It's important to define what
you're saying the complexity
is related to.
So here, I'm saying if we let n
equal to the size of z, can
anybody tell me what the
complexity of this
snippet of code is?
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, precisesly.
Order n-squared.
Why?
Well, because we execute
this for i for loop
here order n times.
Each time through this for loop,
the body of this for
loop is, in fact, another
for loop.
So my approach to problems like
this is just step back a
minute and ignore
the outer loop.
Just concentrate on
the inner loop.
What's the runtime of
this inner loop?
Yeah.
This is order n.
We go through this.
Now, go to the outer loop.
Just ignore the body
since we've already
analyzed the body.
Ignore it.
What's the complexity
of the outer loop?
Also order n.
So now you can combine
the analysis.
You can say for order n times,
I execute this body.
This body takes order n times.
So if execute something that's
order n order n times, that is
order n squared complexity.
So we just multiply how long it
takes the outer body of the
loop to take the inner
body of the loop.
And so in this fashion, I could
give you now probably a
four or five nested for loop,
and you could tell me the
complexity of it.
Harder sometimes to understand
is recursion.
I don't know how important it is
to understand this because
I've never actually taught
this class before.
But Mitch did tell me
to go over this.
So I'd like to touch on it.
So consider recursive
factorial.
What's the time complexity
of this?
How can we figure out
the time complexity
over a recursive function?
The way we want to figure out
the time complexity of a
recursive function is just to
figure out how many times
we're executing said
recursive function.
So here I have recursive
factorial of n.
When I make a call to
this, what do I do?
I make a call to recursive
factorial n minus 1.
And then what does this do?
This calls recursive factorial
on a sub problem the
size n minus 2.
So oftentimes, when you're
dealing with recursive
problems to figure out the
complexity, what you need to
do is you need to figure out how
many times you're going to
make a recursive call before
a result is returned.
Intuitively, we can start
to see a pattern.
We can say, I called on n, and
then n minus 1, and then n
minus 2, and I keep calling
recursive factorial until n is
less than or equal to 0.
When is n going to be less
than or equal to 0?
Well, when I get n minus n.
So how many calls is that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
This is n calls.
So it's a good practice to get
into being able to draw this
out and work yourself through
how many times you're running
the recursion.
And we see we're making n calls,
we can say, oh, this
must be linear in time.
How about this one,
this foo function?
This one's a little
harder to see.
But what are we doing?
We call foo on input of size n,
which then makes a call to
sub problem the size n/2, which
makes the call to a sub
problem of size n/4 and so on
until I make a call to sub
problem of some size.
So this is n.
This is 2 to the 1st.
This is 2-squared.
We start to see a pattern--
2-squared, 2-cubed,
2 to the fourth.
So we're going to keep making
calls on a smaller, and
smaller, and smaller
sub problem size.
But instead of being linear like
before, we're decreasing
at an exponential rate.
There's a bunch of different
ways to try and work this out
in your head.
I wrote up one possible
description.
But when we're decreasing at
this exponential rate, what's
going to end up happening is
that this recursive problem
where we make a recursive call
in the form to sub problem of
size n/b, the complexity of that
is always going to be log
base b of n.
So this is just like bisection
search, where bisection
search, we essentially do
in bisection search.
We restrict the problem size
by half every time.
And that leads to logarithmic
time, actually
log base 2 of n.
This problem is also
If we change this recursive call
from n/2 to n/6, we get a
cut time complexity of
log base 6 of n.
So try and work that through.
You can read this
closer later.
Definitely ask me if you need
more help on that one.
The last one is how do we deal
time complexity of something
like Fibonacci?
Fibonacci, fib n minus 1 plus
fib n minus 2, initially, that
kind of looks linear.
Right?
We just went over the recursive
factorial, and it
made the call to a sub problem
the size n minus 1.
And that was linear.
Fibonacci's a little
bit different.
If you actually draw out in a
tree, you start to see like at
every level of the tree, we
expand the call by 2.
Now imagine this is just
for Fibonacci of 6.
Whenever you're doing big O
complexity, you want to
imagine it and put
100,000, 50,000.
And you could imagine how
big that tree grows.
Intuitively, the point to see
here is that they're going to
be about n levels to get
down to 1 from your
initial input of 6.
So to get down to 1 from an
initial input of size n is
going to take about n levels.
The branching factor of this
tree at each level is 2.
So if we have n levels, and at
each level, we increase our
branching factor by another 2,
we can say that a loose bound
on the complexity of this
is actually 2 to the n.
This is something that's even
less intuitive, I think, than
what we did before with
the logarithms.
So try and work through
it again.
Play with it a little bit.
There's actually a tighter bound
on this, which is like
1.62 to the n, which is a lot
more complicated math that you
could look up.
But for the purposes of this
class, it's sufficient to say
that Fibonacci is order
2 to the n.
So does that roughly clear up
some time complexities stuff
for you guys?
OK, awesome.
Does anybody have the time?
I forgot my watch today.
AUDIENCE: 12:42.
PROFESSOR: OK, excellent.
That gives us a little bit
of time to talk about
object-oriented programming.
Does anybody had any specific
questions that object-oriented
programming?
How about this?
How many of you guys finished
the problem set and turned it
in already?
Or did any of you guys not turn
in the problem set yet?
I'll talk loosely about it then,
not too specifically.
Does anybody have any questions
from, I guess, at
least the first part?
We're making some classes,
making some trigger classes.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Self dot what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: When we
have like self--
we have like the
getter methods.
So what's important
about that?
I'll Tell you what's important
about that.
So we have a class.
Let's say we have
a class person.
So we define our INIT method
to just take a name.
And so now, what the problems
that ask you to do was to
define a getter method.
Define a getter method
called get_name that
just returns the attribute.
So what's the point of this?
Because I can just say
Sally equals person.
So here, I defined a
person named Sally.
And I initialized a person
with the string Sally.
If I just look at sally.name,
that's going to just directly
print the attribute.
So why do we need this
get name function?
What's the point of this
additional getter method?
Does anybody know why that is?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
So that's what it does.
This get_name does return
the attribute name.
But we don't need this method
to just look at
the attribute name.
Let's actually code this up.
So we have class person.
So if we run this code, and
over here in the shell, we
define Sally equals person
with the name Sally.
If I just print sally.name,
it prints the attribute.
So why did I need to provide
this getter method called
get_name that does
the same thing?
That's the question.
That seems sort of redundant.
But there's actually a pretty
big important reason for it.
Let's say we set s name equal
to the attribute sally.name.
If we look at s name,
we see Sally.
Now if I say--
actually, I'm not sure if this
is the correct reasoning.
This is going to be better.
Let's say Sally equals
a person Sally
who's taking what?
1803, 605, 11.1.
So now I can look at the
attribute classes to show
Sally's classes, which
are weird flows.
And I can also use
sally.getclasses to look at
Sally's classes.
If I set a variable s classes
equal to sally.classes, this
binds this variable s classes
to the attribute
sally.classes.
Now if I say sclasses.append
1401, if I now look at the
attribute sally.classes,
it now has 1401 in it.
This is not safe.
This is not type safe.
Because the reason for that is
if you define a class, and you
access the classes' attributes
directly instead of through a
getter method, you
can then do this.
And sometimes, it's
accidental.
You'll set some variable equal
to some attribute of a class.
Then later on in your code,
you'll alter that variable.
But that variable is not a
copy of the attribute.
Yes, you can make copies of that
attribute and stuff, but
the overall takeaway is that in
programming, we try to do
something called defensive
programming.
This isn't defensive.
Because it is possible if you
code it incorrectly to alter
the attribute the instance
of the class.
But if we use the getter
method, if instead of
sally.classes, instead of
directly accessing the
attribute here, we have
set s classes equal to
sally.getclasses.
And then, we had changed
s classes around.
That wouldn't have happened,
because the getter method, it
does return self.classes.
But in the way that Python is
scoped and when we return
something, we're not returning
the exact same thing, the
reference that we're returning
a copy of it.
Does that make sense?
All right.
Cool.
Other questions about classes?
We have a little class appear
if there's like some basic
stuff that you'd like
explained again.
Now's the time.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So here, I'm setting
just some variable s
classes equal to the attribute
sally classes.
it's just like setting any sort
of variable equal to some
other quantity.
AUDIENCE: So you appending the
variable, but it also appended
like the attribute of Sally?
PROFESSOR: So what I did here
was I set the variable s
classes equal to this attribute
sallly.classes.
And then, because I know this is
a list, I appended another
value to it.
But this is the same as when
we have two lists.
If we have a list called a, and
we say a is equal to 1, 2,
3, then I say b is equal to a.
What is b?
Now If I say b.append 1401,
what does b look like?
What does a look like?
Because they're aliases
of each other.
So what I did here, when I set
s classes directly equal to
the attribute sally.classes,
I made s classes an
alias of the attribute.
But the problem with that is
that then I can change them.
And because they're
aliases, the
attribute itself has changed.
And we don't want to do that
in object-oriented
programming.
We need to find an object.
The only way you should be able
to change an attribute is
through some method of the
class that allows you to
change that attribute.
So if I want to be able to add
a class to Sally's class
lists, I should define a method
called define add class
that does self.classes.append
new class.
While technically, it's possible
to directly access an
attribute, it's really bad
practice to do so simply
because this unexpected
behavior can result.
And also because if you say,
oh, well, it's not going to
matter for this one time,
I'll remember how to
do the right thing.
The problem with that is it's
often the case that you're not
the only person using
your code.
So it's a better practice to
provide all the sorts of
methods that you would need to
do with the class in order to
get an access and change
attributes as
methods within the class.
Does that make sense?
So yeah, this is maybe our one
violation if you guys have
been attending my recitation.
Our mantra of programmers
are lazy.
This is less lazy than just
directly accessing the
attributes.
But even though we know that
programmers are super, super
lazy, programmers also like
to be super, super safe.
So when there's a trade off
between defensive programming
and being lazy, always pick
defensive programming.